[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant rien peut-être je peux
passer vous voir non
l'émission
d'accord
une fois de plus alors est-ce que je
peux venir vous rejoindre
merci mais qu'est-ce qu'il a ramené un
petit coeur
[Applaudissements]
non mais j'ai décidé d'être
professionnel
c'est genre tu as pas reçu un message
j'ai reçu un appel oral un message
téléphonique avec un numéro masqué
[Rires]
allez vas-y c'était moi qui l'ai appelé
cette [__]
[Musique]
il faut il faut que vous sachiez chez
vous ce sont des fastes imitation c'est
très court c'est très court mais c'est
très sympa c'est très sympa il y a
Nicolas perdu
de revenir dans l'émission après je vous
cache pas que bon il y a des Américains
stuff qui se baladent et tout
ah tu vas m'en faire un à qui ça
beaucoup plus mal allez c'est un petit
message l'année dernière il m'a dit
franchement Siri j'ai kiffé l'imitation
de sa chaîne base on a beaucoup parlé
c'est Karine Ferri
[__]
[Rires]
c'est pour ça qu'on aime les émissions
puisque j'adore ces missions la France
et les Black Bamber
[Rires]
j'ai l'impression qu'il est là
mais bien sûr qu'il faut donner la télé
dans les prisons pour les agresseurs
évidemment il faut que c'est
divertissent
[Applaudissements]
des gens aussi du bureau que vous
connaissez pas fait nous Lionel Stan le
directeur général le directeur général
c'est une connard maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais que c'est pas mal c'est un
frérot
non ça plutôt 20h45 mon frère ouais
ouais ouais c'est pas mal
[Rires]
il a ouvert une catégorie là catégorie
politique apparemment tu sais faire
François Hollande François Hollande
bien sûr oui
je te dis président de la République
Sarkozy
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Le Pen
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah pardon maman si tu veux
Jean-Luc Reichmann
c'est que sur un mot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Denis Brogniart c'est un nouveau Denis
si vous êtes le générique de Koh-Lanta
sinon je n'arrive pas il faut que j'ai
le la musique
peut-être en faire une autre non sinon
c'est la soupe à la grimace l'épreuve
des poteaux c'est tout et là
[Applaudissements]
Didier Deschamps et Bernard Laporte
Didier Didier Deschamps
c'est vrai que tout le collectif
c'est un très bon joueur il faut voilà
il faut
[Applaudissements]
quand il est doué tu veux pas que je
veux pas lui laisser une note vocale
je vais je vais je vais rigoler
gratos aujourd'hui
dis-nous Michel marine
oui alors il est 18h54
alors ce que Christ
elle rentre dans la pièce
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Didier c'est Didier bon je voulais te
dire voilà bonjour parce que je te
souhaite bon courage pour le match qui
arrive avec Gibraltar en tout cas bon
j'étais ravi de savoir que tu me défends
sur pas que je me suis fait défoncer au
paddle avec Cyril mais bon Cyril il est
plus fort que moi mais bon c'est pas
grave on verra au prochain match voilà
pour le collectif quoi c'est important
[Applaudissements]
tu as fais moi est-ce que tu peux me
faire Benjamin Castaldi
15 20 km
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr il est 20h57 lorsque Siri la
Nouna
entre dans la pièce et il entre dans la
pièce vêtue de ces baskets
des baskets qu'il avait acheté dans le
magasin à côté
apparemment les baskets ont été achetés
au supermarché de Mulhouse alors ce
n'est pas tout à fait ça
[Applaudissements]
comment
merci de m'inviter Cyril alors l'affaire
est très sordide
oui c'était le lundi 4 juin on me dit
que c'était le mardi
alors Gilles vous allez pas me casser
les couilles
[Rires]
et enfin alors et moi il me fait moi
mais très court mais quand j'envoie une
un magnéto sur Cyril pendant pendant ma
chronique et que je le taille un petit
peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui
je m'en bats les couilles de Canal+ on
va appeler pendant l'émission c'est
Cyril Hanouna merci
[Applaudissements]
bon j'ai chronique femme
si je mets tout nu oui
il y a Cyril quand vous quand vous
taquez les bobos de France Inter je vous
le dire mais cela non mais voilà non
mais non
mais c'est bouffon là faut pas que j'y
croise dans la rue de toute façon parce
que je vais leur dire je vais leur dire
et il paraît que tu es en cours Julien
Courbet mais c'est pas encore il y a
marqué en cours
Julien Courbet pour l'instant c'est pas
ou peut-être la semaine prochaine pour
l'instant j'ai juste je veux essayer de
régler le problème avec votre voisin
[Rires]
exactement
alors les chiens il y a une darka j'ai
quand même un faux canal+, votre demande
de rendez-vous a été prise en compte par
notre service souscription
alors il paraît que quoi ton best
vraiment ton ton c'est le rire de Nikos
Nikos bah alors faites-moi une blague
alors
je sais pas n'importe quoi dites-moi un
truc con quoi
ça va loup tu vas bien je suis content
de te voir fils
ça va et puis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans The Voice je suis avec
mes camarades Bigflo et Oli
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur ce monsieur
vous avez un problème avec votre voisin
Cyril je veux le régler j'adore les
fenêtres c'est pas Jean-Luc Reichmann
[Applaudissements]
on commence d'abord par les vicos de la
semaine pourquoi parce que sur ce mot
sur ce plateau il y a des mots qu'on
doit éviter absolument sinon on a les
petits soucis avec comme par exemple les
insultes ou les marques etc ça on n'a
pas trop le droit mais il y a des mots
qui peuvent faire des blessés par
exemple chocolat
sur une séquence lambda de base on a
failli perdre des gens sur ce plateau
Cyril j'espère que vous êtes bien assuré
c'est les vacances de la semaine
les victimes de la semaine
rappelle en 2019 Matt était venu dans
Touche pas à mon poste aussi à cause de
lui c'est parti en cacahuète
c'est pourquoi ou pas parce que tu avais
vu un truc de chocolat
[Musique]
[Rires]
un truc de chocolat
faut savoir que Cyril n'a pas du tout
regardé le magnéto il était en train de
boire mat et lui à côté il s'est dit
mais c'est beau de voir ça quand on
arrive à la télévision
M Pokora et moi là c'est un step je peux
te dire que
tu es bien malheureusement je vais
arriver
aussi et vous considérez où sur
l'échelle de Matt Pokora alors ces deux
styles complètement différents
chacun voit midi à sa porte
malheureusement
je suis sûr parce que cette semaine on
recevait Miss Réunion sur le plateau et
comme si on ne savait pas que vous étiez
là vous l'avez pas annoncé une fois pas
deux fois pas cinq fois pas 10 fois vous
l'avez annoncé 100 fois c'est l'ami de
la prod de la semaine vous allez
comprendre pourquoi
l'ami de la prod de la semaine
[Musique]
d'accord t'inquiète tu m'appelles
t'inquiète
c'est le tour
c'est Miss Réunion c'est très gentil
vas-y tu as une minute 30
c'est une copine
j'ai une copine de la prod pourquoi on a
pas de copine comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est une copine de la prod je
t'expliquerai là justement parlant de
cette copine de la prod c'est venu à
susciter énormément d'engouement
d'intérêt Cyril et je crois que depuis
que je suis à TPMP je n'ai jamais vu un
tel engouement pour une personne de type
féminin vous allez comprendre pourquoi
regarder bien la tête des chroniqueurs
quant à l'autre en plateau c'est magique
c'est les Charo de la semaine
les Charo de la semaine
alors là elle arrive en plateau regardez
bien la tête des chroniqueurs Géraldine
maillot a failli s'étouffer
énager et quand tu as génère à ce qu'il
paraît il aurait suivi jusqu'à la
station rien au mur
sébastopodès allez maintenant regarde de
l'autre côté et il y a encore pire
regardez avec Jean-Mi
il a kiffé
[Musique]
et c'est pas fini on vous a gardé le
meilleur pour la fin avec Bernard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux le revoir
aussi en vrai et elle est venue nous
voir parce qu'elle avait elle était à
Roland-Garros elle était à Roland-Garros
en fait et voilà et elle est venue nous
voir c'est une copine de la prod
je la connais pas du tout en fait elle
est très harmonique elle est venue et
elle va passer les essais pour nous
rejoindre
un petit scout parce que voilà elle a
fait un rendez-vous avec Monsieur Lionel
Stan le directeur général
ah les
connards
[Musique]
c'est tout
Raymond il a bandé vous le voyez
on passe à Daniel
et on passe et à Jean-Michel
il en reste encore un petit peu sur la
bouche là
magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut négocier je peux le faire venir
je vais voir que celui qui avait tiré
une tête assez particulière c'était
Bernard Montiel ma figurez-vous qu'il a
récidivé puisque cette semaine on
recevait vous savez l'influenceur belge
qui a fait croire à ses proches qu'il
était mort et il est arrivé en hélico à
son enterrement bon et bien il était
très sympa il est venu sur le plateau il
avait un petit look atypique bien
regardez la tête de Bernard Montiel
c'est incompréhensible c'est la totalité
de la semaine
c'est super j'adore mais j'adore ça va
c'est incroyable
voilà donc Ragnar arrive en plateau et à
côté de qui il se place Bernard
les réseaux sociaux
[Applaudissements]
on passe à mon magnéto préféré de la
semaine
à votre avis qui est la plus grande
chaudière parmi les chroniqueuses Daniel
je vous pose la question qui fâche comme
ça
la première vue oui on pourrait se dire
oui c'est ça madame mais en fait bravo
Hugo
elle se cache derrière sa pancarte
[Musique]
vous allez voir en plus elle n'assume
pas du tout Cyril c'est incroyable on
l'a appelé tout simplement la mytho de
la semaine
la mytho de la semaine
j'ai retrouvé votre mec ce weekend sur
ma vie
ouais moi aussi mais je me force je
pense à autre chose tu vas moi je suis
assez discrète quand même sur ma vie
c'était plus du tout l'amour
que j'ai Bacqué
sur cette up comme la misère sur le
monde
tu vois un peu c'est un peu ça l'idée
moi je suis assez discrète quand même
sur ma vie
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
on dirait comme quand le matin vous
arrivez près du grip hein
je pose des questions à tout le monde je
pose des questions
mais c'est vrai pas les mêmes questions
[Rires]
ok on accueille tout de suite une photo
de maths pokora oui
il y a quelque chose pas mal il est beau
hein sur les chaînes vous vous sentez je
vais te dire la vérité tu as deux gars
comme ça qui arrive en soirée
la soirée bascule je suis désolé les
mecs excusez-moi
excusez-moi
Géraldine oui en fait c'est deux styles
différents il y a un brin ténébreux avec
une forte pilosité et un blond imberbe
un peu scandinave et en même temps ils
ont des points communs ils sont un peu
habillés pareils ça arrive en soirée
franchement mais j'ai tout de suite
instantanément je me dirige vers la
chemise blanche
tout de suite ça tu vois il y a quelque
chose d'un peu matos tu restes à la
soirée on arrive tu restes à la soirée
pour les deux même faire un choix ça
sera ça sera la soirée bascule je vous
dis la soirée bascule la soirée parce
que je connais ça arrive la soirée
qu'est-ce qu'ils font dans la vie pour
en avoir rien à [__] comme ça ils
arrivent et éclate le bonheur à la
gueule j'aime pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
monstrueux il est magnifique non il est
pas beau Guillaume franchement mais
franchement on dirait un peu Matt Pokora
avec une version une autre version un
autre style mais c'est blond comme ça il
a des dents magnifiques
et son épiderme artisan et son épiderme
j'y vais aussi non
gilberté
par contre toi tu arrives tu nous
échelle de l'humilité vous c'était où à
peu près
madame je rigole je disais que c'était
au dessus en plus
on dirait qu'il y a ah il y a un
magicien dans la soirée
[Applaudissements]
dans des soirées où ils veulent mettre
des magiciens parfois c'est une énorme
thalass parce que bon on adore mais tu
es en train de chez Bron tout ça il y a
le gars il était obligé de galerie ah
ouais cool et d'autres et
le 9 de trèfle il était là
incroyable il reste souvent il reste là
il reste tout à fait un ou deux fois et
là qu'est-ce qu'il y avait marqué quoi
tu fermes ta gueule tu vois c'est fou et
tu pensais à ça tu pensais tu vois c'est
fou mais c'est fou merci je peux
reprendre mon petit carnet des habitants
tu veux faire un dernier truc avant de
partir ah si je fais c'est que avec vous
Reichmann
salut à tous bienvenue dans les douze
coups
mais j'adore les douze coups de midi
c'est l'heure de la question que la
question in c'est l'heure de la question
et je suis avec mon ami Georges salut
Jean-Charles bonjour Jean-Luc oui je
recherche
attention oui Lilo vient de
Clermont-Ferrand bonjour Comment ça va
aujourd'hui je suis très content d'être
là vous avez une petite anecdote à nous
raconter je crois alors Clermont-Ferrand
parce que j'étais à Clermont-Ferrand et
donc j'étais avec mon frère parce que
j'ai un frère de votre frère j'ai un
frère jumeau comment il s'appelle votre
frère Jean-Marc on
envoie
et donc j'étais avec mon frère du monde
en voiture
et donc là je baisse la dite et je
demande en fait la rue Mouffetard ce
magnifique et qu'est-ce qui se passe à
rue mouffet racontez-nous
Clermont-Ferrand et donc il y a une
personne qui nous dit là où Mouffetard
ce serait pas à Paris c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible et ça s'arrête là oui
c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]